[Music]
the celestial emergence in the movie
eternals brought up one thing to mind
another gigantic planetary science
mechanical monster yeah the way tiamat
was a part of the earth was very similar
to the transformers the last knight's
unicron so here in this video we will
assess everything about these two
planet-sized robots we will take a look
at their origins from both the
live-action movies and the original take
we will talk about their sizes which one
is bigger their powers or supposed
powers that they must possess and how
similar they are to each other as well
as how different they are plus we will
have a bonus round on who will take the
crown in a fight between these two
humongous entities
so let's get down with this sickness
let's start with the origins of tiamoth
the dreaming celestial also known as
steamer the communicator was a celestial
whose job was to inform the fulcrum a
god in the marvel universe of the
celestial's findings during planetary
inspections and send signals to the
horde a swarm of mindless insects to
collect the planet's aggregate life
force and deliver it to the fulcrum when
the first celestial host came to earth 1
million years ago timoth was one of the
10 members in it he was created before
the current seventh universe began and
was later imprisoned in the earth by a
collective power of all the other
celestials when he challenged and
defeated arishim the judge
in the mcu however tiamat the
communicator was a celestial who had his
scene sown on earth his development was
fed by the sentient energy of the
world's inhabitants and guided by the
eternals so a celestial seed was sent to
earth millions of years ago as
determined by the prime celestial irishm
the judge the seat had an influence on
the earth burrowing deep into its core
to rest and grow it would take a lot of
energy from the core
its minerals the earth's minerals and
also energy from sentient life-forms to
grow as with all celestial birds this
seed was given the name tiamut and it
began to grow using the energy of the
human race that lived on this host
planet
now let's shift to the other end and
let's talk about the origins of unicron
from the comics the animated series and
the original take on this monster so in
the beginning order and chaos coexisted
before the dawn of time in an extra
dimensional entity known as the one he
created unicron as an astral creature to
explore the young cosmos and then
subdivided him to make primus his twin
brother both brothers were multiversal
singularities one of a kind in every
reality he is also known as the lord of
chaos the chaos bringer and the planet
eater he is on a mission to consume the
entire multiverse planets moons stars
whatever and even the fabric of creation
all in greed to power his gigantic body
in the live action movies its timeline
unicron is a cybertronian god of chaos
who is the size of a planet he is primus
and cybertron's twin brother and an old
foe quintessa the prime of life mentions
him in a transformation last night and
aims to destroy him by draining his life
with the staff causing him to awake
well billions of years ago the planet
earth developed around the dormant body
of unicron it is unknown however as to
the extent of his being inside the
planet when cybertron was making its way
to earth the six horns of unicron began
to sprout out from the interior and grew
at three meters per day so the entire
last knight movie was to prevent the
awakening of unicron and sending back
cybertron to space to prevent a
cataclysmic battle when he awakes which
means the earth will be no more
so let's go to our favorite topic size
as a celestial tiamat can alter his size
to whatever suits his needs in the movie
eternals the celestials were seen as
cosmic beings larger than planets and
even stars with scenes showing them
creating solar systems and stars all
over the universe however teamwork was
just a baby in this timeline he was
inside the earth as a seed and grew from
the energy of the core and essential
life forms that means us humans when he
emerged in the end of the movie his head
towered over the clouds and even reached
the upper stratosphere which means that
his head alone would be around 40 to 50
kilometers in size and as weta digital
vfx supervisor matt aidkin tells us
timoth the celestial born from the
earth's score in eternals is a whopping
300 miles tall or 500 kilometers from
head to his feet
now what about the size of the last
knight's unicron of course over the
years we have seen many iterations of
unicron in the animated series and
comics and he has always been the size
of a planet and sometimes the size of
jupiter around a hundred thousand
kilometers in height he can also alter
his size to suit whatever situation he
is in in the last night not only was
unicron the size of earth but was planet
earth itself so in this version of him
he is dormant and was curled up like a
ball and over time space debris
accumulated around him and thus became
earth so if he was to uncurl himself and
transform into a humanoid robot then he
would have been three to four times as
tall as the diameter of earth putting
him in the range of thirty to fifty
thousand kilometers in height
now let's get to our next favorite part
powers teamwork like other celestials
would have emerged and become a cosmic
creature of unimaginable power and
magnitude he would be immortal as a
celestial able to live indefinitely
without dying of old age well the only
way he was killed was when the eternals
after combining their own cosmic
energies with his own to form the
unimine something that would only have
happened due to his own wish
so you can say that he sacrificed
himself to save us humans so if alive
teamwork would have been able to
manipulate massive amounts of cosmic
energy in order to generate stars life
and planets all over the galaxy and
the universe being a celestial he would
be one of the greatest energy generators
of the cosmos he would have been able to
travel instantly everywhere using black
holes and change size at will as well as
communicate telepathically
so now what are the powers of unicron
now it has been pre-established that all
unicrons throughout the transformers
universes are the same multiversal
singularity so his powers would be the
same throughout the multiverses unicron
has the ability to control other
entities by bestowing powers on them and
has the ability to transform he can
morph into a massive mechanical robot
capable of consuming other worlds he has
the ability to detect things in multiple
dimensions and knows what is going on in
the cosmos at any one time he can
control matter in a variety of ways
including transforming it to energy he
can travel through dimensions and
consume other realities by passing via
black holes he has demonstrated to have
the ability to grow in size at will
unicron has the ability to swallow
space-time itself resulting in the
creation of pocket dimensions and
universes
so how similar are they to each other
when seen from a lay man's perspective
then both these two would be near
identical to each other both are encased
within the earth and both of them emerge
slowly with the head and the left hand
of teamwork arising from the inside of
the planet and in the case of unicron
his horns started to rise from different
locations across the world
both have golden metallic exteriors and
both have powers that are near
incomprehensible to humans but that's
where it ends so how different are they
well unicorn and teamwork differ very
much in size during their specific
emergencies the unicron being the planet
itself was way bigger than the initial
size of termite at 500 kilometers or 300
miles being earth itself unicron was
just dormant and life began to flourish
on his exterior while timoth needed
sentient life energy to grow and mature
over thousands of years in the core of
the planet here in these timelines
unicron is way over being over 4.5
billion years as the planet earth while
timothy was just in the million year
range from seed to emergence
now the bonus round what if they fought
each other the animated flicks unicron
and the comic steamer would have a hard
time with each other as they both will
have similar powers and can change sizes
in accordance to their wishes they would
both fight to a standstill but what
about the mcu teamwork versus the last
knight unicron well if it comes to
physical blows then the transform
unicron would wipe the flow clean with
tiemoue's face but then again a new born
human would not have the experience and
would have had difficulty in cosmic
energy manipulation but if he was able
to use it to his maximum extent then
tierment could defeat his foe by using
the cosmic energies to implode unicron
from within but the results of this
fight will be left to you guys to decide
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video and with that we come to the end
of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam